the star of rumble in the Bronx Jackie
Chan and all-time NBA scoring champ
Kareem abdul-jabbar
crackling it's an honor to present the
awards for best short films with you I'm
a big fan of your movies
likewise you know Karine it's my honor
to I've been tractus all your move
really yes so you like the skyhook ah
besides sky hole you know like the
cement move grey move in boots leaves
game off the debt yeah hey pal we've got
a couple of Oscars to take care of for
Best live action short film the nominees
are rooms Luke Cresswell and Steve
McNicholas
Duke of Group Griffin Dunne and tom
koehler Lieberman and look Christine
Lahti and Jamison memo little surprises
Jeff Goldblum and Tiki Goldberg Tuesday
morning ride
Diane Houston and Joyride and the Oscar
goes to you read it and the Oscar goes
to Lieberman in love Christine Lahti and
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you so much I must share this
great honor with all the nominated
directors with all the other men and
women out there struggling to make short
short films but guys I'm going to keep
it at my house okay I have to thank
Lesley Hoffman Steve Hewitt Polly Platt
mark rosovsky Lisa Bromwell and a great
crew my cast especially Danny Aiello and
Nancy Travis my husband Tommy Lonnie who
inspired and supported me every step of
the way
Emma Joan Wilson Mike treasures I love
you and dad at home and mom you're right
here tonight forever this is for you and
now thank you - Jenna memo Thank You
Showtime John Vaisey Hillary rips Tom
call well and especially Roy Lang board
and my parents good night Molly and Zoey
thank you
[Applause]
Jackie time to order the art of brevity
once again the nominees for best
animated short film are the chicken from
outer space
John R Dilworth a close shave Nick Park
[Applause]
the end Chris Landreth and Robin Barger
gagarin Alexa Cara TV runaway brain
Chris Bailey
and the Oscar for best animated short
film is presented - Jackie can you read
that
the Oscar goes to close shave
Nick
[Applause]
[Music]
it's an honour to being in the company
of such great animators thank you I've
got a speech I'd like to thank the
entire crew and staff of Aardman
Animations in Bristol the animators
everyone else who worked on the film
also a Peter Sellers nan Reed for
lending their voices and to woloson when
Deline Colin rose and the BBC and I just
like to thank my parents for allowing me
to play with their 16 8 millimeter cine
camera when I was 13 and I think they've
regretted it ever since but so to
wallace and gromit and all the crew and
everyone else back home thanks a lot we
did it again
thanks he returned with Sandra Bullock
Steven Seagal Martin Landau and the
Oscar for Best Supporting Actress
you